from your experience in submitting man
in a box to some of these film festivals
you've probably learned your own sort of
doing do's and don'ts checklist yeah for
a future short that you plan on making
right and what are some of those things
that you've learned man man in a box
that process it was really great that
Kevin included me you know in the
festival submission process because it
gave me an education that I didn't get
in film school or anywhere else of you
know kind of navigating the festival
circuit and kind of figuring that out
one of the big things I can say about it
is you got to get your you got to get it
in early that was something I think that
we went up against with a lot of the
submissions with that we were running
into deadlines and you know especially
with a suspense movie especially with a
feature-length you want to get it into
their hands as early as you can I mean
right now I want to say that there's
close to 10,000 short films submitted to
Sundance they only screen 200 you know I
mean your odds are very small so the
sooner you can get it in their hands the
better shot you have you know if you
wait which I know happened to us that
there were some festivals that we really
pushed the deadline you know and there's
no way to quantify whether or not that
was the reason that we didn't get picked
up by those festivals but I think that
was a big learning curve was just you
know realizing that you know yeah just
because the deadline is September but
you know if they've already accepted 500
from the early you know July submission
what shot do you have so that would be
number one is get get the film in as
early as possible even if it is in in a
rough cut state and that's something
that Kevin I also went back and forth
with was do we submit it as complete as
possible and there's no right or wrong
to it I know
there's a lot of films that are
submitted almost as work prints where
they don't have you know all their
special effects and place they don't
have you know music and they're kind of
throwing up title cards at certain spots
where their stuff missing you know for
us we wanted it to be as complete as
possible we wanted it to have the best
shot that it could and I think we felt
that it being in too rough of a state
you know might have you know lessen the
chances so for this short film that you
plan on making soon do you have an idea
of where to go to look for festivals
that will fit that genre and that time
length well yeah there's there's
definitely you know festivals like in la
that are geared towards short films but
naturally i wanna i want to cover as
many as possible you kind of have to
factor that into your budget you know
when you know when you're making a film
is you know the festival submission
charges and but for me exposure is
everything I don't wanna I don't want to
limit myself to just you know the
festivals that are geared towards shorts
I want to submit that film to everything
that I can afford so and knowing that it
is a short film do you think you would
throw it up on YouTube or Vimeo after
work after you've already done your
festival runs yeah I mean um the entire
thing yeah and this actually is
something that I talked to Kevin about
to with man in a box and it's something
I plan to do with my short film capsized
is that having kind of a tier system for
exposure where you know we're going to
target the film festivals first and then
probably do live stream and some you
know other opportunities for facebook
and you know different people that are
part of our social network first you
know almost like you know hey sneak peek
you know please you know for everybody
that shares this you know we're going to
do Q&A sessions and we're going to do
this and do some you know live streams
that we have control over before
we just kind of blindly throw it out on
youtube because I feel like you kind of
have to build up as much buzz as you can
with your own website with your own
network your own social marketing before
you just go here it is on YouTube wish
in a prayer is anybody going to search
for and find it so YouTube is going to
be the last step for me
you